[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
China now has the most advanced facial
recognition program in the world today
in China you can withdraw cash buy
groceries and check in at the airport
using only your face the Chinese
government already has a hundred and
seventy million security cameras
watching they're 1.4 billion citizens
beyond this they have an ambitious plan
to soon place 400 million new cameras
across the entire country where they're
ever advancing supercomputers in facial
recognition software they soon expect to
monitor all of their citizens movements
finances and even emotions did you know
the Bible says that someone is already
recording your every thought word in
action stay with as friends we're going
to learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions
welcome listening friends this is Bible
answers live I am Doug Batchelor pastor
Jean Ross is out of town on his way
overseas on a mission trip right now but
we're going to be studying the Word of
God together and before we go to the
questions and our free offer for tonight
we want to begin the program with prayer
loving Lord we thank you for the gift of
your word and for the promise that
knowing the truth will set us free we
pray tonight Lord that the truth in part
or in whole will liberate the listeners
and so please bless for your glory we
ask in Jesus name Amen well friends I
started with an amazing fact about China
I've made several trips to China I was
privileged in 2014 to present one of the
first public evangelistic meetings in
China
ever since communism took hold and just
an incredible country lovely people but
the government can be a little
overreaching and the fact that they're
not only monitoring now their people
through facial recognition software
they've got cameras everywhere they're
watching every car they look at the
license plates they know where they are
people's phones cell phones are
registered they know who is on the phone
and who is not and where they are based
on the GPS on their phone and they're
even using their facial recognition
software for ethnic identity and you
know there's some Muslim Chinese people
in part of the country that have been
persecuted and they've developed this
software so it can even identify the
race of somebody they're watching all
the time and it's not getting better
it's almost like the fulfillment of
George Orwell's 1984 but do you know
this is really nothing new you know the
Bible says you have always been watched
there has always been someone who sees
your every move
jesus said in the judgement will give an
account for every idle word that we
speak and that's Matthew chapter 12 and
you can't hide from
he sees everything even though Jonah
tried to flee from the presence of the
Lord he should have known better Psalm
139 verse 7 where can I go from your
spirit or where can I flee from your
presence if I ascend into heaven you're
there if I make my bed in hell behold
you're there if I take the wings of the
morning and dwell in the uttermost parts
of the sea even there your hand will
lead me and your right hand shall hold
me if I say surely the darkness will
fall on me even the night will be light
about me indeed the darkness shall not
hide from you but the night shines as
the day the darkness and the light are
both alike to you can't hide from God in
the dark Bible says he sees everything
he sees everything we do he hears every
word that we speak and what's more he
knows every thought you think man looks
on the outside God looks on the heart
that's why we need the gospel in a new
heart Hebrews 4:13 there is no creature
hidden from his sight but all things are
naked and open to the eyes of him to
whom we must give an account and you
know the Bible tells us that 2nd
Corinthians 5:10 we will all appear
before the judgment seat of Christ that
everyone might receive the things done
in his body according to what he has
done whether it be good or bad everyone
will give an account someday to God and
stand before Christ to determine what
have we done with our lives and if we
have sins that we have not placed on
Christ and confess and repent ative
there's an accounting for that and
that's why it's so important for us to
take advantage of the gospel and the
pardon that God is offering us I don't
want to go to the judgment have my life
reviewed I already know too much that
I've done that would disqualify me and
I'm looking to Christ in His mercy you
know we have a free offer that talks
about that coming judgment and the mercy
that God offers we would like to make
available for free
it's called pending your case in court
pending your case in court that number
eight hundred eighty five six seven four
seven that's for your free offer one
more time for the free offer that called
this number asked for
pending your case in court it's free
you'll be blessed by eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and we
I'm looking at we still have lines open
if you want to call and get your
question in on tonight's program that
number is 888-259-3826 teen verses 11
through 12 so both of them have jewelry
mentioned like mention it in a good way
so can you explain why jewelry is talked
about in the verses and those way yeah
and you know a number of protestant
church is not so much today as it used
to be didn't wear any jewelry they
thought and the verses the reason for
that is because you find verses like
second Peter chapter 3 where he says do
not let your adornment be outward
adorning arranging the hair wearing gold
or putting on of apparel and then you
can read in them whereas it Timothy
where Paul says in like manner the women
adorn themselves in modest apparel with
propriety not with a braided hair or
gold or pearls or costly clothing and
then the real deal breaker was there's a
verse in Isaiah chapter 3 where talks
about the proud daughters of Israel were
be decking themselves with her ring
so what is it Isaiah three starts with
verse eighteen so then you find verses
like Song of Solomon and Ezekiel where
it talks about women in a wedding or how
God adorned his bride in Bible times
they had no money paper money and when
people gave gifts they would often for
money they'd give jewels an example of
this would be when Abraham sent his
servant Eliezer to find a wife for Isaac
and part of the dowry was it says he
gave her a bracelet he gave her a nose
ring and maybe earrings too I don't
remember but and it tells the weight of
them because it was it was a cash gift
and that's how they had money back then
when the children of Israel spoiled the
Egyptians to get payment for their
slavery the Egyptians gave them their
jewels our gold and silver so forth and
that's what they used to dedicate to
build the temple they also melted some
of it down to make a golden calf so that
was the money so what you the two cases
you mentioned I think are in relation to
a wedding and when they had weddings
they would you know give a dowry and
they'd give gifts and it was often in
form of jewels the New Testament
principle is one of simplicity and
modesty and I want to make it clear you
know there's going to be a lot of
Christians in heaven that wore jewelry
the more conservative Protestants like
myself I don't wear any jewelry part of
the reason is because a few years ago
you remember all of those televangelist
got in trouble you know was it the late
80s and they even wrote songs about
would Jesus wear Rolex and they talked
about the ostentatious attire of the
evangelists and their wives and Christ
talks about modesty so the principle I
think is one that you know we don't want
to do anything else to make somebody
else stumble and so I think that
Christians should not be wearing jewelry
I have a book I've written on that I
know some people are shocked to hear me
say this I know one thing I'm not gonna
stand before the Lord and the judgment
and have the Lord say Doug I can't let
you in you didn't wear enough jewelry so
I have a book I'll send you a free copy
it's called jewelry how much is too much
jewelry how much is too much and Daniel
I don't know what you think is it just
my imagination or are people piercing
everything they can possibly pierce
these days and hanging all kinds of
golds and beads and you know it starts
small and it seems like as the culture
deteriorates the external display gets
bigger what do you think yeah yeah I
believe that it just people do piercing
wherever do Jersey yeah it's in so you
know you have to always ask a Christian
is a follower of Christ what would Jesus
do and since Paul and Peter they say let
it not be the gold and the pearls but
let it be the inner light that adorns
you that's what we live by thank you
very much appreciate your call and don't
forget that free offer jewelry how much
is too much going to talk next to let's
see Joel who's calling from New York
Joel you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi how you doin doc back to
them doing great thank you for calling
oh well I'm confusing a little bit about
I just wonder you know why in the Bible
in the beginning you know Aaron wasn't
attacked by by the devil a steady eye
line it was Eve I wonder why it was a
something that I'm confusing a little
bit why it you know the devil attack II
why did you add on mm-hmm well why did
he go to eat this or the other
I just confusing a little bit well I
think of it this way the devil is waging
war against God and he knew that God had
just made this new world and these
creatures in His image that he loves
very much
you know God spoke the creatures into
existence but when he made man he formed
him with his own hands and he kissed the
breath of life into Adam and so God
loves man as any parent would love a
child indeed more right the devil wanted
to hurt God and so he went after the
weakest this is what you do in war you
look for the weak part and the woman the
Bible says that women at least
physically are weaker vessels he saw the
woman was by herself so she was more
vulnerable and the devil exploited that
and he thought I'm gonna get to Adam
through Eve now that's not the first
time that's happened how did the devil
get to Samson through Delilah how did
the devil get to David through Bathsheba
how did the devil get to Solomon
so Solomon loved many women and they
drew his heart away after other gods so
he's done this all through history
knowing that men have very soft hearts
when it comes to women and so the devil
thought I'm gonna get to the man through
the woman okay so it's a great question
and I you know if you've not signed up
for the amazing fact study guides in our
third study guide it talks about the
fall of man and I think it's called
did God create a devil if you call the
resource line and ask for that study
guide on did God create a devil the
number eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven that's the number
for the free resource did God create a
devil and if you have a Bible question
it's eight hundred God says thank you
very much for your call and I'm gonna
talk next to Helen calling from I think
it's Colorado Helen you're on the air
with Bible answers live you mean how can
we help you so yeah my question is how
do I survive the church that problems
that is so discouraging just to go there
every week and then it's got ever gonna
do something to save this church well
you know you're not alone don't be
discouraged Helen and I'll answer your
question and briefly I want to tell you
right now that I wrote a book for
someone exactly like you and it's called
how to survive in church and I've got a
chapter that talks about surviving and
big church small Church dying Church
spiritually but you'll be encouraged by
that don't give up you want to go and be
a witness in that church and what the
devil wants is to discourage us are to
get us to look at people now keep in
mind that when Jesus walked the earth he
had his Twelve Apostles
even among the Twelve Apostles Jesus
dealt with arguing not only did Peter
and John and James argue about who had
the highest position Jesus had a thief
in the Treasury Department and so and he
had unbelief among the elders and the
pastors the disciples Jesus said where's
your faith they often lost faith and
they forsook him and fled and denied him
and so but they were the ones God used
to change the world don't get
discouraged if you see people bickering
and and some people are hypocrites in
the church you keep your eyes on Jesus
and do your best to be a good example
you know Abby does not make much honey
by himself you got to be in a hive and
so you want to stay together you're
gonna be a football player you need a
team an army you need soldiers that will
group together so stick with it and
remember it's not the pastor's church or
an organization's Church it's the Church
of Jesus and you want to make you know
if you have sometimes you're in a big
city and there's other churches in the
neighborhood that are more biblical and
more edifying you want to go if you can
a lot of people live in small towns
where you know next church is a hundred
miles away and you've got to make the
best of what you've got so check out
that book how to survive in church and
you can call 808 three five six seven
four seven I think I have a sermon by
that title you can listen to for free on
YouTube and just you can type in Doug
Batchelor how to survive in church
thank you very much Helen I hope that
helps a little bit I'm talking to Peter
in New Jersey
Peter you're on the air with Bible
answers live yes best I'm just gonna
switch phones for a second no problem
there we go that's better turn pester
certain verses in the Bible say that
were to edify one another we're to there
with each other's burdens and be
together with each other then there's
certain verses like in Timothy that says
were to turn away from certain people
then you have verses like in third John
that say if someone comes to your door
without this document of the Bible don't
even give them greeting
do you know when to it's time to turn
away from somebody what a bear with
somebody well if someone is getting
confused doctrinally your first effort
would be to reconcile them redeem them
because James says that if you turn a
brother from the error of his ways you
will you know save a soul and cover a
multitude of sin so always you want to
be redemptive when a person is settled
in their ways and they're just coming to
a church and causing division by false
teachings you don't want to jeopardize
the Sheep by letting a wolf in and so if
that person is unrepentant and they're
not open to you know going along with
Bible teaching at some point I just had
a talk with our pastors this week
there's somebody that we needed to deal
with that had no intention of following
the Bible they kept coming to the church
to try to recruit people for their own
teachings their own group and we finally
had to say look this is private property
you're not welcome because you're your
as a pastor you're caring about the
sheep and if someone says look I've got
these issues I'm concerned can you study
with me that's different and you try to
edify and build them up and help them
and teach them and and you know kind of
carry them through their struggles but
when a person is settled in their ways
and they're not gonna change at some
point don't open your door shake the
dust off your feet as Jesus said I know
it sounds a little brutal does that make
sense would that be the same thing also
with the unsaved world that people that
we know well you know you always want to
work to try and save the Lost if you've
got somebody that is just a you know a
scoundrel trying to hurt the church and
persecute and they don't have any
redeemable they're not at all open then
you know you do what you can to jesus
said and I know this is really hard but
he said do not cast your pearls before
swine and don't give what is holy to the
dogs and Jesus said there's some people
you just got a call I'm a brood of
vipers and move on that's what John the
Baptist did so you need judgment and
discernment because you got it you know
you're dealing with people's souls and
you want to be as patient as possible
but you also have to be realistic some
people you're just spinning your wheels
if you
spend all your time trying to turn them
around hope that helps a little Peter
good question and very realistic one
alright gonna talk next to Linda in tech
Connecticut hi Linda you're on the air
hi pastor how are you doing good
appreciate your calling I thank you for
your ministry um pastor I was wondering
about the immutability of God's
character of the night in reference to
the Sabbath although that's a whole I
mean that you of course there's many
sermons about that but I'm talking about
where it seems like the Bible
contradicts God's immutability it says
in a few places that God is unchanging I
believe that and I'm shooting Bible
studies with two different people and
they brought up this thing about the
Bible contradicting itself and I thought
the only thing I could
what example did they give you what
example did they give you of the Bible
contradicting itself in Jonah
with Jonah yeah Oh God said through
Jonah he was going to destroy the
Ninevites but then he didn't First
Samuel I think 15 and I think Jeremiah
eighteen seventy 11 explains that oh but
I think these people are just well yeah
well let me talk about Jonah for just a
second and before I do answer I'll
mention I have a book called the sign of
Jonah
and I'll send you a free copy and it's
808 three five six seven four seven and
asked for the sign of Jonah talks about
that but what God said about his
prophecy of the Ninevites God never
wanted to destroy them if he was going
to destroy them why bother sending Jonah
at all just rain fire on them
he sent Jonah to warn them hoping they
repent which they did so his judgment
was conditional in other words God said
look if you don't turn from your sins in
forty days and Nineveh is gonna be
vaporized or whatever he was going to do
and they'd be destroyed but they did
repent and so God extended their mercy
and it wasn't actually until home
probably over a hundred years later than
invites turned away from God again and
they were severely judged but all
through the Bible in Ezekiel it says if
the wicked man chapter 18 if a wicked
man turns from his wickedness and does
what is righteous he will live if your
repents and turns Bible says if we
confess and Forker forsake our sins we
will have mercy
that doesn't mean God's inconsistent
that means God's merciful which is the
whole message of the Bible so you know
some of God's prophecies were clearly
conditional the prophecies that God gave
through Moses in Deuteronomy 28 he said
if you love me keep my Commandments all
these blessings will follow you but if
that means it's conditional if you don't
all these curses will follow and
whenever they obeyed they got the
blessings when they disobeyed they cut
the cursing and that's still true today
so yeah I find the Bible is the most
consistent book God says I am the Lord I
changed not Hebrews 13 Jesus Christ the
same yesterday today and forever and
Jesus said the heaven and earth will
pass away my word will not pass away
God is extremely consistent those who
are looking for inconsistencies or
you know they're often there digging for
something and and in my opinion they
don't ever find anything with much
substance as for that free book Linda
and we thank you for your call 883 five
six seven four seven can I try and get
in a couple more calls before the break
and we're going to talk next to blessing
in
Illinois blessing you're on the air with
Bible answers live Oh
pasta dog thank you I've been trying to
talk to you forever I want to thank you
for taking my call
absolutely so we got just a couple
minutes for the break how can we help
what's the question
oh I'll leave it across 11:00 I want to
know how it applies to us today all
right no Leviticus 11 God says speak to
the children of Israel here's the
animals which you can eat among the
animals on the earth and then he
identifies animals you shouldn't eat and
the Lord isn't commanding us that we
have to eat animals he's saying if
you're gonna eat animals don't eat
unclean animals and he specifies that
among the mammals there's a couple of
guidelines if a mammal was clean for
food and that also meant it was clean
for sacrifice it needed to be
cloven-hoofed and chew the cud it needed
both characteristics because you got a
camel that chews the cud but it's got a
paw pad it's not cloven hoofed and
you've got pigs that are close enough
but they don't chew the cud camels and
pigs are unclean
whereas goat dear sheep cows they chew
the cud they've got a cloven hoof
they're in the clean category and they
could be used in sacrifice among the the
sea life it needed two things it needed
to have fins and scales and there was an
interesting study done by the Navy I
think it was in the 50s where they were
telling soldiers after World War 2 a lot
of pilots got shot down and we're in
lifeboats in the water they didn't know
what they could eat and what they
couldn't eat of the sea life and they
came back with a study and it said if it
had fins and scales it was safe for food
and all they had to do was read the
Bible and then the for the birds the
bird category is not as clear but when
you look at the different birds that are
clean and the ones that are unclean
probably the best way to describe it is
the foraging birds were clean the birds
of carrion the Raptors were all
unclaimed Eagles and crows and the
omnivores the foraging birds like
chickens and turkey and doves quail
pheasant they were all clean for food
so God said if you're gonna eat meat eat
the clean ones well now with modern
science we know some of the worst things
you could eat are unclean animals
especially scavengers like pigs or dogs
I know people are surprised to hear me
say that but in some part of the world
they still eat dog and these are basic
health laws these are not these are not
ceremonial laws that passed away with a
cross it's still true today even in the
New Testament God said command the
Gentiles that they obey these laws and
they weren't to eat anything that still
had blood and they weren't to eat
anything that were strangled with the
blood still in it meaning the health
laws were still intact
Peter says in Acts chapter 10 Lord I've
never eaten anything common or unclean
this is years after the crucifixion and
people think that God was saying it's
safe now to eat unclean food but Peter
has this vision he never takes anything
out of the sheet and eats it and so you
know we have a study on that we'll send
you a free copy blessings and it's
called God's free health plan God's free
health plan call 883 five six seven four
seven and you know friends if you follow
the principles in God's Word on healthy
living not just the clean and the
unclean foods but there are principles
on exercise rest work diet water
sunshine and all in the Bible and you
get that free health plan lesson and you
will have a longer stronger more
abundant life it's been a real blessing
to me we're going to take a break you
hear the music we're not going away we
would invite you to continue to call in
with your Bible questions and we'll be
back after these short announcements
[Music]
stay tuned
Bible answers live will return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
chart and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore com or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273
25 it is a my Moses we usually insert in
prayer why don't you ask is it allowed
to use these days in Korea nowadays yeah
well certainly there's nothing wrong
with using instance in prayer and keep
in mind what happened in the sanctuary
in the Old Testament were symbols when
you read in Revelation it talks about
the incense the smoke ascended and it's
a symbol of the prayers of the Saints
that are brought before the Lord through
the merits of Jesus by God the spirit
and so in the same way we don't need to
sacrifice lambs now because Jesus is our
lamb the incense that was a symbol of
the intercession of Christ and the
spirit and our prayers going before God
it's not required there's no nothing
morally wrong with your having some
incense in your house for the fragrance
I don't believe you needed to make your
prayers more effective you may enjoy
just the the smell of it I remember when
I was doing meetings in India in Madras
or Chennai India years ago that they
always had incense burning not for the
fragrance but because the mosquitoes
didn't like it
the mosquitos away so I got used to
preaching with incense swirling around
me during that time but yeah it they use
incense as a symbol of the prayers in
Exodus chapter 37 verse 25 thank you for
calling in from Ghana Africa Emanuel
hope that helps a little bit and we do
have that study guide you can read
online about God drew the plan it's on
the sanctuary that you read about in the
Bible you can just go to amazing facts
dot o-r-g and look for the study guide
you search it God drew the plan you can
read that for free online
I know it's take too long to get the
lesson to you there in in Ghana Africa
talking next to crews in Bakersfield I'm
assuming California crews you're on the
air with Bible answers live yes good
evening pastor bachelor evening I'm so
happy
good evening I'm so happy I got through
I have been having this question like
for a long long time Exodus chapter 3
verse 24 and I just want to know what it
means when after he drove the men out he
placed the east he placed on the east
side of the Garden of Eden cherubim and
a flaming sword flashing back and forth
to guard the way to the Tree of Life and
my question is what is the light
flashing back and forth means and is it
still there alright good question now
you said exits but I think you meant
Genesis 3 yeah I know where you're going
it's ok
oh you don't be we're all friends you've
got the correct
you've got the angel with a flaming
sword a first question is he still there
no and the reason is that since the
world was covered by a flood in the days
of Noah the next time you find the tree
of life in the garden appearing it's in
heaven and now you can't prove this but
it's reasonable that in the same way
revelation 21 says the New Jerusalem is
going to come down from God out of
heaven at the end of the 1,000 years if
God can bring the city
he can bring a garden up and many
scholars believe that before the Lord
destroyed the world that he assumed or
he caught up the garden in the Tree of
Life to save it because God had planted
that garden himself he's gonna restore
it to man after the world is made new so
that's not you know a critical point to
argue but the Angels probably not still
there guarding the tree because the tree
is not there oh he got sent to guard the
way to the Tree of Life
lest man eat of it and live forever now
there have been you know a lot of
conquistadors and people have been
looking for the Fountain of Youth in the
Tree of Life and they were looking for
the living water in the Tree of Life all
these rumors and we pretty well got the
world mapped right now and I don't think
the Garden of Eden is still here there
are some places that looked like the
Garden of Eden when they were first
discovered but and then what is a
flaming sword that the angel held you
know it's a mystery I'll just say that
the angel had some kind of weapon of
glory and the people will see that they
start thinking of Star Wars but we don't
know exactly what it is it's you can
read another place where an angel of the
Lord is over Jerusalem during a plague
and he's got his sword drawn and David's
season but it's you know we don't know
what kind of sword this is I mean Bible
talks about a war in heaven between
Michael and his angels is in Revelation
12 and the dragon and his angels what
kind of weapons do angels use in a war
then you're eating a seal nine it says
that God sent these angels through
Jerusalem to punish and destroy and they
had each had a destroying weapon in his
hand it's you know when we get to heaven
we'll probably understand the mechanics
and dynamics of these flaming swords but
they've got like the glory of God in
them or something yeah we think lasers
or I mean it's hard for us to imagine
what angels are using and think about
how much our technology has learned
since in the last hundred years if you
and I went back 100 years and tried to
explain to the settlers what a
smartphone is or what a radio wave our
television is they think it was
witchcraft so imagine when we get in
heaven and we see the things that angels
are using
Oh Paul said we can't even imagine it
Wow that's amazing but I was just
wondering I've always wondered what it's
the flashing back and forth man it was
that like them it could mean that yeah
the angel was moving it back and forth
just to let them know that this is
you're not to pass this way kind of like
you've probably seen soldiers like at
the the the Unknown Soldier tomb and
you've got the honor guard marching back
and forth it's like they're making their
presence known by their continual
movement and the angels just saying you
know this gate is guarded until the
garden is opened again and in heaven
we're gonna eat from the tree of life
again as well thank you very much for
your question Cruz and with that we're
gonna talk to Wilfred Wilfred calling
from Brooklyn New York you're on the air
with Bible answers live hi Doug good
evening evening I would like to know why
did Jesus wait until he was thirty years
old to begin his ministry good question
I think the answer is that you can read
in I believe it's is it Exodus or
Leviticus that Moses said a priest was
not allowed to serve as a priest in
Temple till he was 30 and it's also you
weren't really considered a man until
you were thirty not you know will draft
people now at sixteen seventeen eighteen
not 16 but seventeen eighteen people
snuck into the army but in Bible times
when you're in your 20s they still
considered you a youth when David fought
Goliath he was not eight or ten years
old he was probably twenty David then
ran from King Saul for several years
David became King at thirty Joseph went
out over Egypt when he was thirty years
of age two symbols of Christ David and
Joseph and a priest could not serve as
priest until he was thirty and I think
you can only serve until you were 55 so
Jesus when he knew he would be respected
as a rabbi you had to be thirty I
believe to serve in the Sanhedrin if he
wanted to be a respected rabbi they
waited until you were 13 you had a
little life experience
to your belt looking back now I'm 62 I
think when I was 30 I was just a kid I'm
twice that old now I hope I've learned
something but take it out alrighty
thanks great question appreciate it all
right that frees up a line if you want
to call any with your Bible question
once again eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven and we're gonna
talk next with Dave calling from North
Carolina Dave you are on the air with
Bible answers live hi how are you sir
I'm doing great and how are you doing
I'm doing well so first I want to say
praise to the Most High and it's such an
honor to get to talk to you out there
watching you 40 some years now and I
find the amazing facts in ministry it's
very powerful so you know I think a God
for little thing will thank you that's
very kind how can we help you tonight
with a question yes sir I was wondering
if you could give me a breakdown of
first Corinthians chapter 15 and at
verse 29 verse 29 all right let's go
there real quick and it says here
otherwise what will they do who are
baptized for the dead if the dead do not
rise at all why then are they baptized
for the dead this is a verse that first
of all let's let's use the process of
elimination some people read this first
and they go baptized for the dead I
thought they was happy yeah yeah I
thought once you die the Bible says it's
appointed demand wants to die after that
the judgment and you know everything
else in the Bible says that when you die
your destiny your works good or bad are
sealed and you'll be judged based on
that and the idea that someone could
live a wicked life and someone else will
all get baptized for them no every
person is accountable for their own soul
the only time there can be substitution
for your soul is the sacrifice of Jesus
so that must happen while you're alive
after a person dies their destiny is
fixed so what does this mean this is an
example in the bye
we're translators struggled with
punctuation the original Greek had no
punctuation and when you properly place
the punctuation this verse makes sense
now let me tell you the whole context
you can look in first Corinthians 15
Paul's talking about the resurrection
he's laboring with the Corinthians who
were struggling with whether the
resurrection already happened or will it
ever happen and Paul says otherwise what
will they do who are baptized then it
should say comma for the dead comma if
the dead don't rise at all comma why are
they baptized for the dead and so once
you see so what Paul is saying is if you
don't believe in the resurrection then
why are you getting baptized then after
the word baptized you should have a
comma it says for the dead comma if they
don't rise at all why are they baptized
and then he asks a rhetorical kind of a
little bit of a sarcastic question are
you getting baptized for the dead not
saying you should do it he's saying it
would be absurd so he said if there's no
resurrection why even bother getting
baptized
so yeah Paul is not recommending that
people get baptized for the dead there
there is at least one denomination that
does that and it's kind of dangerous for
a person to think well I'm not going to
give my heart to Jesus now I'll have my
kids and my grandkids do it I'm just
gonna live for the devil no that's
exactly what the devil would want people
to think once a person dies they're
gonna take their they're gonna take
their life record to the judgment with
them and nobody living can change their
destiny there is no purgatory
there's no limbo that you can pray or
pay a personality of does that help a
little a lot like okay Paul were you
talking about here you know that's a
common question people read along and if
you use the typical punctuation you go
what does that mean so here I thank you
very much for your call Dave it's good
to hear from you and we're gonna talk
next I've always wanted to talk to Joe
Louis Joe you're on the air with Bible
answers live from North Carolina hey
pastor Doug hi how are you doing I'm
good my question
is how you know if God forgives you when
you commit the same sin over and over
and you ask him for forgiveness does he
forgive you like when you ask him or
well if he doesn't all right well yeah
well I don't know if that makes sense I
think it does I think it makes perfect
sense
all right so you're struggling let's say
you're struggling with a habit or a
behavior that you keep you fall let's
suppose your problem is gossip I'll just
make that up as an example and you know
gossip is not good and you catch
yourself gossiping and you say oh Lord
may the Holy Spirit convicts you you
said that was not right I shouldn't have
said that I am so sorry and you pray and
say God forgive me and you're sincere as
soon as you ask and you're sorry God
forgives you
now does that mean you're never gonna
gossip again no you may slip in that
area again the Bible says a righteous
man falls seven times and rises again
you do not stay down you get up that
eighth time and the Bible tells us Mary
Magdalene out of whom Jesus cast Seven
Devils and so don't be discouraged the
Bible tells us I think its job says he
will save you out of six troubles yes in
seven no evil will befall you Christians
may often have left to weep at the feet
of Jesus for the same mistake I feel
like I am sorry I don't need to cry but
I feel like I'm taking advantage of
God's mercy well the very fact that
you're you're regretting that is a sign
the Holy Spirit is still working with
you because you feel conviction but you
know the only way you're ever going to
overcome is through God's mercy right
right so do you think the Lord wants you
to stop asking for power and forgiveness
or does the devil want you to get
discouraged and give up
devil devil wants you to give up
repenting you know how many times I had
to quit smoking before I quit smoking
now I haven't had a cigarette in 40
years now but I used to smoke and it was
a struggle and I throw away my
cigarettes and I pray and ask God to
forgive me and then I'd go smoke again
and I throw him away and I'd pick him up
again and I can't count how many times I
played different games to try to quit
and I repent and ask God for help
he was a struggle you know but you know
what finally the day came where I got to
where I was so desperate that God just
needed to really bring me down to the
bottom where I got to the place where he
gave me victory a lasting victory now
Joe God wants you whatever your issue is
God wants you to have a lasting victory
do not get discouraged keep in mind the
promise your God is bigger than your
devil greater is He that is in you than
he that is in the world do not be
discouraged because your promises I feel
like ropes of sand and you keep failing
if you fall again tell the Lord exactly
what you're telling me say Lord I
believe you love me but I feel like I'm
taking advantage of your mercy and I
don't want to sometimes we sin and we
think I'll just ask God to forgive me
tomorrow and then we realize that's not
the right way to think but tell the Lord
that say I don't want to take advantage
say I want a lasting victory in this
area and he can give it to you would it
be okay if I pray with you Joe before we
sign off oh yeah please can I do that
yeah Father in Heaven I just like to
pray that you be with Joe and thousands
of others listening just like him we are
struggling with something in our lives
it might be a habit behavior could be
some addiction and we repent and we're
genuinely sorry and then we make the
same mistake help him not to be
discouraged
I pray that he'll know that you are a a
bigger Savior than he is a sinner and
that you'll give him grace you've
promised that your grace is sufficient
and help him to have of that lasting
victory
break the chains Lord and set him free
and so please bless Joe encourage him
that you love him and give him strength
and if he should fall again I don't let
him be cast down but to turn back to you
again and trust in your mercy and then
get back up and so bless him and
everyone we pray in Jesus name Amen
hey thank you Joe and you know Joe there
is a book that I think you would be
encouraged by and don't be scared by the
title it's called is it possible to live
without sinning it's kind of a
provocative title but it's meant to be
we'll send you a free copy and you can
even read it online if you go to amazing
facts idato RG the book is called is it
possible to live without sinning free
book will send you 808 three five six
seven four seven appreciate your call
gonna go back now to Texas and talk to
Michael Michael you're on the air with
Bible answers live how are you doing
third very good and your question
tonight I have two things but my
question is in Ezekiel talks about the
watchman three different times yes and
his job and in the last part of each one
it talks about it if you do not tell
them they will still surely die but
their blood will be on your hand does
that mean for today as we're going
through life and there's someone that's
put on our lives and we know we need to
tell them and then we're separated and
never to see them again in never total
that's a great question so if you read
Ezekiel 33 in there's other places but
mostly a chapter 33 talks about the
Watchmen on the wall
and I hear a little road noise Mike so
I'm going to put you on mute just why I
answer this they're wondering does that
mean and it says look if you see an army
coming and the watchman doesn't blow the
trumpet and warn people that army may
come and destroy the city but I'm going
to require the blood of the citizens at
the hand of the watchman who fell asleep
on duty and didn't warn them
if you warn them and they don't take
cover they may die but you've delivered
your soul because you did warn them
that's a principle in life really for
everybody now I've got some young
friends that read this and they think
pastor Doug does that mean that I'm
supposed to everybody I see I'm supposed
to grab them by the collar and say jesus
is coming repent and if I don't tell
everybody their bloods on my hands no
that obviously would not be a practical
way to live but there will be people now
keep in mind as eql is a prophet he is
called as a special watchman he's given
a special message of warning for the
nation of Israel and God was saying to
Ezekiel you better lift up the trumpet
and tell him
pastors are Watchmen teachers
evangelists that's why James said don't
rush to be a teacher because you're more
accountable greater responsibility but
every believer to some extent God will
bring people into your lives he'll put
them on your hearts and you know you
should be a witness Jesus said you are
the light of the world let your light
shine if we have people that we have an
opportunity to witness to and we neglect
it oh that's dangerous business now I'm
glad for God's mercy because there's
been many times God has impressed me to
talk to someone and and I've been afraid
and those opportunities passed and I've
asked God to forgive me there have been
times he impressed me to talk to people
and I did talk to him and some came to
the Lord and some mock me he doesn't
promise they're all gonna listen but
that's really what it's talking about
here in Ezekiel is that tell some extent
were all to let our light shine when God
places someone in our path and he puts
him on your heart and now if you're
working in you know some public offices
you can't go from desk to desk and talk
about Jesus so they're just gonna fire
you so you have to use wisdom and tact
and diplomacy hey thank you Michael and
I'm putting you back on the air did that
help a little bit does that make sense
yes I understood that and I know it's
not a loss of salvation because
salvation is in Christ alone but it
still sticks out several times and in
detail that that their blood will be
required would that be something when we
stand in front of the Lord on the
judgment and say yes you know I know we
won't stand with the people that are
being cast but we will be standing there
and he's going to show us all things
you know I cry crying isn't until the
third or fourth chapter revelations
wiped away will that just be that we
will know at that moment what we did and
did not do and great questioning yeah
let me let me talk about that real quick
so in the judgment are we going to be
aware yes and even the redeemed I think
will recognize God's mercy it's in
Revelation chapter 21 Eden dries all
tears from our eyes but there may be a
period of time where we're aware that
there's some we love that did not make
it that there are opportunities that we
neglected and we'll probably have some
remorse but we you know God will wipe
away our tears and we'll be thankful for
the people that we didn't influence for
eternity you know Jonah was reluctant to
go to Nineveh but when he finally went
the whole city repented so kind of a
lesson for us to take advantage of those
opportunities to say a word for Christ
all right we're gonna try and get in
another call or two um let me see here
all right talking to Daniel from Florida
I believe Daniel you're on the air with
Bible answers live hey Pastor Dan taking
my call I appreciate it I've got like a
minute and a half can we do it okay
I can so we're reading in numbers 22 the
story of Balaam who's my kids and they
asked me to explain why God would send
an angel to confront Balaam and try and
kill him he's got sold Balaam he could
go so I was wondering if you had any
insight on that verse I could share with
that yeah that is a good question
so originally
when Balaam said can I go and get this
reward for cursing in Israel God said
don't go I'm not with them well they
came back wanting him to come again and
they asked him to come one more time and
they said we'll give you more money and
God could see Balaam was bent on coming
because he wanted the reward his heart
wasn't right and God said all right look
if you want to go you might be going
into the valley the shadow of death and
when Balaam was going who knows what was
going through his heart when he's going
down the road with his donkey and
evidently he had a couple of servants
with him - an angel stood in the way and
said I'm here to resist you now keep in
mind angels do not miss if they swing if
God really wanted to kill Balaam he
wouldn't have missed he'd be done for
the angel was warning Balaam look your
your way is not right you shouldn't have
even gone on this trip but you wanted to
go
an angel stood to resist Moses when he
was going into Israel because he was
neglecting a duty of circumcision or one
of his boys and you know sometimes
angels come with promises of blessing
sometimes they come with their swords
drawn as a warning and that's what was
happening to Balaam God said look you
think you're gonna go and curse these
people and you want the reward and you
want the honors and you're kind of
wishing you could curse him a Balaam
later he does go totally sells out to
the enemy and he ends up dying a lost
man it's kind of sad and he's mentioned
again in Revelation for that but hope
that helps a little bit thank you James
for your call and give the kids
greetings hope it helps a little bit
listening friends we don't have enough
time to do justice to another caller and
if I see several lines still lit up if
we didn't get to your call tonight I
hope you'll give us another chance
and God willing we'll be back again next
week I want to remind you that a lot of
the answers can still be found right now
if you go to the amazing facts website
simply amazing facts dot o-r-g if you
type in amazing facts dot-com or dotnet
it'll all take you there and if you've
been blessed click on the button there
and just send us a little note let us
god bless you the truth will set you
free we'll talk again together next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven immediately that
moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com
[Music]
for over fifty years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we've built churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website
[Music]
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 may sing fact zero RG
[Music]